BTS proved dynamite for McDonald's.
The fast food operator said quarterly revenue rose 57 percent...
...and profit more than quadrupled after getting a lift from sales of a celebrity meal...
...inspired by the Korean boy band.
McDonald's launched BTS' meal that includes chicken McNuggets and fries in nearly 50 countries.
The chain also got a lift from its new crispy chicken sandwiches it launched in February.
Same store sales for the world's largest burger chain jumped over 40 percent.
It exceeded pre-health crisis levels for the second straight quarter.
McDonald's sales and profit topped estimates despite facing staffing shortages.
The company said finding enough workers for its restaurants...
...was still, in its words, "challenging."
Larger order sizes and price hikes helped offset higher cost for labor and ingredients.
McDonald's raised its guidance for fiscal 2021,...
...citing the quicker than expected economic recovery.